Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this new age of AI, there is no shortage
of articles and discussion about AI safety,
and of course, rightfully so: these new learning
algorithms started solving problems that were
previously thought to be impossible in quick
succession.
Only ten years ago, if we told someone about
half of the things that have been covered
in the last few Two Minute Papers episodes,
we'd have been declared insane.
And of course, having such powerful algorithms,
we have to make sure that they are used for
good.
This work is a collaboration between OpenAI
and DeepMind's security team and is about
introducing more human control in reinforcement
learning problems.
The goal was to learn to perform a backflip
through reinforcement learning.
This is an algorithm that tries to perform
a series of actions to maximize a score.
Kind of like playing computer games.
For instance, in Atari Breakout - if we break
a lot of bricks, we get a high score so we
know we did something well.
If we see that happening, we keep doing what
led to this result, if not, we go back to
the drawing board and try something new.
But this work is about no ordinary reinforcement
learning algorithm, because the score to be
maximized comes from a human supervisor and
we're trying to teach a digital creature to
perform a backflip.
I particularly like the choice of the backflip
here because we can tell when we see one,
but a mathematical specification of this in
terms of movement actions is rather challenging.
This is a problem formulation in which humans
can overlook and control the learning process,
which is going to be an increasingly important
aspect of learning algorithms in the future.
The feedback option is very simple: we just
specify whether this sequence of motions achieved
our prescribed goal or not.
Did it fall or did it perform the backflip
successfully.
After around 700 human feedbacks, the algorithm
was able to learn the concept of a backflip,
which is quite remarkable given that these
binary yes/no scores are extremely difficult
to use for any sort of learning.
In an earlier episode, we illustrated a similar
case with a careless teacher who refuses to
give out points for each problem on a written
exam and only announces whether we have failed
or passed.
This clearly makes a dreadful learning experience,
and it is incredible that the algorithm is
still able to learn using these.
We provide feedback on less than 1% of the
actions the algorithm makes, and it can still
learn difficult concepts off of these extremely
sparse and vague rewards.
Low-quality teaching leads to high-quality
learing.
How about that!?
This is significantly more complex than what
other techniques were able to learn with human
feedback.
And, it works with other games too!
A word about the collaboration itself.
When a company hires a bunch of super smart
scientists and a spends a ton of money on
research, it is understandable that they want
to get an edge through these projects, which
often means keeping the results for themselves.
This leads to excessive secrecy and a lack
of collaboration with other groups as everyone
wants to keep their cards close to their chest.
The fact that such collaborations can happen
between these two AI research giants is a
testament to how devoted they are to working
together and sharing their findings with everyone,
free of charge for the greater good.
Awesome.
As the media is all up in arms about the demise
of the human race I feel that it is important
to show the other side of the coin as well.
We have top people working on AI safety right
now.
If you wish to help us tell these stories
to more people, please consider supporting
us on Patreon.
Details are available in the video description,
or just click the letter p that appears on
the screen in a moment.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!